it's the beaver bling no one can take
their eyes off road trip gotten down on
one knee in the Bahamas Haley Baldwin is
sporting the huge diamond on that finger
so it must be true right the internet
went into Bieber hysteria when news
broke and possible engagement with
Haley's dad Steven Baldwin seemingly
confirming than deleting this tweet
sweet smile on my face me and wife Kenya
always pray for God's will he is moving
in the hearts of JB and HB Bieber's mom
was quick to follow that up with love
love love love love love love well
Justin's dad Jeremy posted on Instagram
this photo with the caption proud is an
understatement excited for the next
chapter the happy couple's love goes all
the way back to what Bieber was 16 years
old and promoting his documentary Never
Say Never and Haley was just 14 years
old and a believer with her dad on the
red carpet over the years the two
developed a close bond showing up in
photos with each other and friends but
it wasn't until December 2015 that the
PDA really started putting the rumors to
rest that the two sealed it with a kiss
on New Year's Eve but sources close to
the couple suggested that it was just a
fling yet in a February 2016 GQ
interview Justin tells the magazine
quote what if Haley ends up being the
girl I'm gonna marry right if I rush
into anything if I damage her then it's
always gonna be damaged it's really hard
to fix wounds like that it's so hard I
just don't want to hurt her
cute 2017 Selena Gomez then on-again
off-again love of Biebs enters the
picture once more things cool off with
Haley as she spotted with fellow
Canadian Shawn Mendes in May 2018 Haley
and Shawn attend the Met Gala together
but insist they're just friends Bieber
and Selena once again call it quits and
surprise surprise Bieber is caught
kissing Haley and this TMZ video from
June a month later alien beaver are
seemingly engaged in Selena well her
friend posted this pic of her Sunday
smiling away enjoying some Sun on a boat